hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jesse I'm Jesse and today's gonna
be a short stream because I have
somewhere to be in less than an hour so
we're going to try to do one Pomodoro
session of code and also my camera keeps
cutting out so I may just switch to my
screen and if the camera cuts out I'll
just I'll let it cut out usually when
this happens I can bring it back for a
couple minutes but if I really want it
to work for longer than a few minutes I
have to completely restart my computer
which I don't have time to do right now
I do want to say I want to give you an
update on this project very quickly
first and then I'm gonna let you know
what we're gonna do today then we'll
start the timer
well one Pomodoro session and and then
new questions after that so the the
project now officially has a deadline we
have a launch date so this is not a hard
launch date it's a self-imposed launch
date so you know we're not gonna get in
trouble if we don't you know hit the
date but I'd like to go for June 4th so
it's the first Monday in June
I'd rather launch on Monday and then
that way I have all week in case
anything goes wrong to work on now we
were gonna go for June first but that's
a Friday and that's the worst day to try
to launch something so so that gives us
about seven weeks so there's gonna be
other things that come up during that
time so I can't spend you know every
single you know day of those seven weeks
I'm also gonna probably go to a
conference at some point between now and
then so that's gonna take a few days but
I've broken things down and I haven't
haven't typed these up yet there's just
written on a
Notepad so I'm gonna break it down
really quickly I'd like to within the
next week
fix some things with the menu to include
all the links and that's what we're
gonna start doing today and then I'd
like to take another week and connect
the the search inputs and the a bar and
in the side nav to the actual search
function and then clean up that search
with the few remaining things that we
really we needed to do then for the next
three weeks I just want to bring data
over so that we have all the data there
I'm not gonna work as much on making it
look nice yet that's we're gonna save
that for the end and then get all the
routes working so that if you go to one
of the old URLs it will take you to the
new page and then whatever time is left
when we need to set up the the WordPress
installation I want to make sure that
that's on a server that can handle the
load that it's likely to get so that'll
we'll do a week for that that get leaves
us with about a week left for anything
else that comes up so it's gonna be
tight but I overestimated how long I
think these things will take so
realistically I'm expecting you know to
have more than one week so we'll see how
it goes but that's the timeline for
right now and the bulk of that is
transferring data over so that's I'm not
going to do that on the stream because
that's just boring it's just me going
through spreadsheet double-checking URLs
I'm hoping to get some help from student
workers and kind of going through data
and cleaning things up so hopefully I
can get some help with that and that
should should help I want other people
double-checking that we've successfully
migrated the content and then all the
links still work
also today I haven't McDonald's coffee
so anybody from McDonald's if you're
watching you could sponsor me with free
coffee and then I'll tell everybody
every day that I drink me Thomas coffee
so let's see all right so let's switch
over now and we'll get to it well let me
show you what I want to do first
obviously okay so here's what's gonna
happen for this stream
Rohit asked if that was the dollar size
coffee yeah it is so like this is the
large but the small medium and large
coffees are all $1 so obviously I'm
gonna buy the large right even if I
don't really need that much coffee I'm
gonna buy the large and just drink it
anyway
right now I'm really like I really love
the McDonald's app and I keep trying to
find the best deals so I try to figure
out what combination of coupons will
will get me the most food for the least
amount of money so on this particular
page we have this side menu so these
menu items do not appear in our main
menu up at the top which we've moved to
the side nav all right so my my camera
cut out I'm just gonna leave it out
let's see so we need to put these
somewhere so there are two places where
we're going to put them so for both
mobile and and desktop we're going to
take let me bring this over I'll just
open it up cuz I don't know where I put
it
so let's open up localhost and actually
I can start anger out for this as well
so let's start anger out and let me
paste this for you all
you can check out the project as we are
working on it with this n growth link if
the link doesn't work for you right away
then try copying and pasting the link
instead of clicking it and then that
usually works alright so you know feel
free to click around or you know do
whatever inspect it so basically right
now we have this menu here it's just
like one level deep so we have these
main categories and that's it you can't
go any farther but really all of these
options here have I shouldn't say all of
them most of them have sub menus so what
I'd like to do is make it possible for
these items to also be opened up and
have that sub menu items displayed it's
gonna be a little tricky in terms of
indentation because we're gonna start
running out of space we'll see but we'll
just see how it looks you know we could
afford to make this this navigation menu
a bit wider if we need to so that's what
we're gonna do today we're gonna try to
make these sub menu items have the
possibility of having sub menus
themselves also and this is we're
probably not we're not gonna get to this
today but what I'd also like to do is on
certain pages so let's let's find one so
like on desktop we'll make a floating
nav here that just kind of Scrolls with
the user that would have menu items
we've done something similar to this and
react with material UI on a previous
project so we're gonna look at how we
did that and this will probably be in a
stream tomorrow or you know some other
day this week
so anyway so that'll just have like an
extra for the desktop that we don't
really have room for on mobile but I
think it will be very helpful for a user
to not have to go
get into this menu anyway so that's the
idea if anybody has any thoughts on that
put them in the live chat I'm gonna
start up the timer and let's get to work
mmm oh yeah I have this okay drawer item
is where you wanna be let me make sure
that I have the most up-to-date stuff
all right cool so did it get pool it's
up to date and let me make this a bit
bigger all right that might be too big
okay so here is beside this ok so right
now we're just dealing with drawer item
for now we're gonna need to edit some of
the data so that we can support this
this functionality so I think we already
have everything that we need with the
expansion and so
okay yes so right now we're already
doing the this expand items on click so
what we need to do then mister Stane
okay I do want to keep these as links so
let's try so you have a list and then a
link and then the list item inside of
here
okay
and here's here's one of the problems
that I'm thinking of so these are
actually pages that they are linked so
we want these to be clickable so and I'm
open to suggestions on this do we want
to have a little icon here that is
separate so that if you click here it's
still a link but if you click on this
icon it actually drops down the menu or
should we just make the first item in
each submenu be the link in these
themselves are not actually links let me
know if you don't understand what I'm
saying
or what you think about this because we
definitely need to we need to decide I
think what would be will it make them in
a sense I don't know I don't know what
users will expect so I mean some of
these won't have the links so it is
gonna have the behavior that you can
click it and it is a link so users will
probably expect that all of them have
that behavior so I'm thinking maybe like
a clearly-defined button here with maybe
a vertical border to separate it out but
we're definitely going to need to change
the way things work in here let me so
many items with map all right so what
we're gonna need then is a ternary to
check to see if the submenu items have
so many items but Erin says couldn't the
submenus be drawers
they they could be chores but I'm just
wondering on mobile is there enough
space for that originally I wanted them
to be extra drawer that like came out on
the side here and then I realized
obviously that there's no space on
mobile for that to happen we can at
least start with the turn here because
we're gonna need this no matter what
really just trying to think what I want
to call this the hardest part of code
and figuring out what to what to name
things so I guess some menu if item
that's sub sub menu if item got sub menu
then
then we're gonna do whatever we're going
to do here so for now I'll just put let
me copy this let me do a dead first
okay so what I will be doing here is
just making two of these alright so
here's what we have and I probably
messed this up how to mess this up
oh I'm returning things automatically
and it should not be is that how do they
if we have a sub menu item then we want
to turn else we want to return that no
why is my mind blanking we've done this
on the stream so many times what am I
missing let me do any parens
it's
okay so those in
put a return before the condition okay
actually
do I need I return can I switch this
back to what we had I should be able to
switch it back to what we had now think
about it
I just have to go to another component
and see how we did it my mind is
blanking this is so silly
I guess I didn't use that exactly in
there
okay I don't need that is that my
program
okay yeah
yes I should still need this
all right I mean my indentation is crazy
for this and it's not Auto formatting
probably because of the errors all right
so where am i this should be fine do
this link I just I'm not sure why why am
I getting this
there we go I was missing a paren all
right cool
does that ever happen anybody's like you
go to do something you've done a million
times before and then all you just can't
remember the syntax okay so what we
should get then is if our data
I let me double check and make sure
didn't break this first know it okay not
broken excellent
okay so right now none of our data has
submenu so it's going to this which is
what we've already had so it still looks
the same which is exactly what we want
so now we want to add in something extra
if there is a submenu for that piece of
data for that item so that we know this
is actually working so for now I'm just
gonna add in I don't know
I'm gonna add this and this should be
pretty ugly if we add it and oh yeah I
know I have the data up here somewhere
said pretty much never close it drawer
menu yes here's the data we'll move it
over here so we can see them both at the
same time so let's grab let's just use
this this first one it'll be easy so on
the about menu is that our first one
yeah under academically excellent we're
going to add submenu and we'll just say
true for an out if I could spell it
you and that so submenu is true what
we're gonna need to do is actually put a
sub menu so sub menu itself is going to
be in an object it's going to be an
array of objects but for now we'll just
do true and what this should do is make
this messed up no maybe I'll refresh it
just to be sure
did I misspell it I did sub menu there
we go
there we are okay so all the rest of
them work you know just like they should
work and then now under academically
excellent
we have submenu right okay so this just
proves that it works now we can actually
create you know something a little icon
or whatever we want at this point so
let's work on s let's work on that okay
yeah let's just let's work on getting
that icon there for now
oh this is the wrong project I'm looking
at that like what is going on different
projects okay so let's go in here and
see I said let's go in and dev tools in
Chrome first so I just want to see like
what what's going on what kind of styles
are already there so what would be the
best way to modify this so what I'm
gonna try to keep this clickable as a
link and then add in something like this
that is not part of the link so the
actual a here which the a tag is let's
see what it styles are you
alright let's just mess around and give
it see what we can can make it do
maybe this is where I need to put it on
this dead
alright let's see No
why's my
foods
let me shoot my time I think I'm running
out of time if I can find my timer it's
back here all right six minutes oops
grab the wrong Oh y'all can't see me
anyway I was I went to drink out of the
wrong coffee cup okay what is going on
in here that I can't put these in
different actually I mean I guess I
could use grid I could use the grid to
make this happen I probably should do
that I be better to just use what's
built-in okay I mean I'm gonna have to
import grid which I do we already have
the grid imported here
whoops another search there we go
all right let's see how we did this good
container great item so let's just grab
this so we have it's yeah this should
work so if we're gonna have submenu
items we're gonna change this this div
is gonna be our our grid container and
then we'll have a grid item within there
just our grid and this is the grid here
and then we're gonna make another grid
item for our our sub menu icon part so
for this nine and three let's try 19 3
and now we may not have to do any custom
alignment at all if this works guess I
forgot to close something yep and the
grid system that we're using comes with
material UI so some of these components
or components that we created and then
other components or components that
we've gotten from it's your UI alright
cool so we we do have this this
positioning here let me refresh just to
make sure any styles that we had are
gone ok so right now this is extending
past here which is it's ok because we're
not gonna have an actual word here is
just gonna be one icon
okay so I mean unfortunately this forces
this onto two lines it's not the end of
the world we could definitely mess with
the indentation a bit to try to make
this give us some more space the icon I
think definitely I don't think it really
needs that much space really so we could
I think we have more padding than we
need
yeah let me just let's see what you want
your supporter left let's go with two
pixels solid and what are we gonna go
with RGB a zero zero zero zero point
five four
I think actually I want this to be
thinner and lighter let's go wonderful
there we go
okay so we'll probably have a divider
here so that this is clickable and we'll
also take away this padding padding
right it's gonna be zero just make sure
that that's a flood okay padding right
zero and then that way when we hover
over it will go directly up to here
padding right zero now that extends down
below I don't like that what if
yeah you know what we're gonna have to
make that border appear on on this div
it's just gonna have to be within here
otherwise it's gonna look weird when we
hover okay so my timer is up but
basically this is what this is what is
gonna happen now in terms of style right
it it'll basically be an icon like this
over here and so they'll be divided but
when you click on this icon there'll be
another set of items that show up which
will be may be slightly more indented
probably the same color though I don't
know that I can go that much lighter I
could potentially go with a slightly
thinner font and see how that works
just to add like another visual
indication of hierarchy and the menu
items but that's we're going to going to
do so the way we would do that then is
add into our our data under submenu
instead of true we would add an array of
objects that would look exactly like
this and that that's what would populate
another submenu so in the same way that
we're looping through that we're looping
through submenu items here they were
mapping over them we would we would have
another map within this portion for a
for a submenu so we would have a like a
collapse right and then we have a whole
other submenu so that's what needs to be
done for this to be finished
I may save this and finish it in a shame
tomorrow I mean I do have a lot of data
to be transferred over that I could do
not on the stream so maybe I'll save it
let me know in the chat if if you would
like to see how we would finish this
component
and you know if if it's something you
want to see then I'll definitely hold
off on finishing it until the next live
stream and if you're watching this later
and you can't participate in the live
chat let me know in the comments please
alright so that's what we have so far
let's just want to do a get okay
normally I wouldn't I wouldn't commit at
this point because it's slowly like half
finished but I want this to be available
to all of you to be able to check out
what we've done so far so that's why I'm
gonna commit this as is so the link to
this repository is in the description
it's available for you to you know take
any of the code use it for whatever you
need to use it for if you want to submit
pull requests that's awesome as well
let's see a new feature scope for this
change to add
submenus for so many layers okay
no breaking changes and I don't believe
we have any open issues dealing with
this I may have them but I'm in a hurry
right now so all right so I'm gonna
scroll all the way up to the top of the
live chat answer as many questions as I
can I think based on what's in the live
chat now I there shouldn't be a problem
in getting to everyone's questions today
all right great that worked passed all
the tests awesome now we'll do a git
push there we are Boston all right so
now all this code is available to you
all to to do whatever you want to do
with all right so a lot of people saying
hi hey everyone
oh I'm she says you are the most starred
get repo holders oh it really is the
free code camp repo the most art that's
awesome
domain you cat says you really need the
best deals with your salary yeah
unfortunately I do um yeah I mean
realistically you know if you save a few
like let's say I can get the food for
half of what it is so I don't know like
instead of five dollars it would be two
dollars and fifty cents you know that
adds up I mean that's I don't go every
day but let's say I go twice a week I
save five dollars a week let's say
there's four weeks in a month you know
that's $20 a month that's over two
hundred dollars a year and that's just
for McDonald's so I mean you can see if
I do the same thing at the grocery store
or at other restaurants to everything
you know that's yeah it doesn't sound
like a lot I guess but still it's I mean
that's money that go towards something
for my kids or my wife or you know just
say you know saving it for you know an
emergency
I mean I'm not saying that I'm poor or
anything right I think I'm I can pay all
my bills and so I'm thankful for that
but I'm not at the point where I I can
just say forget it I don't need qfo see
some kid says can we use style
components for styling all our
components yeah I mean you can normally
like for what we're doing in this
project there are some situations that
we we can't use it eventually though I
would like it to get to the point where
we we can use like react like in
component styles for everything it's
just going to take a while to get the
data to the point where that's gonna you
know be doable so that's the goal I
think you know if we really work at it
we could get there you know by the end
of this year but I know already my boss
is talking about the next like two
projects that I'll be working on after
this one so I think there's gonna be
it's gonna be harder for me to justify
keep working on this project when it's
already launched especially if it
launches well and there's no issues it's
trying to make the argument that like a
it'd be really cool if we could clean up
this data it's gonna be a little tougher
so I really do hope it happens but it's
it's going to be something that happens
just a little bit at a time
California boy says because of the small
screen on mobile you should have defined
buttons I'm not sure where you what you
mean I mean I'm assuming like we're
getting you know we're gonna have
buttons in terms of like an icon on the
side therefore the menu items so I guess
we you know we are doing that
okay Youssef says maybe on mobile the
new drawer could just replace the old
drawer that's that's actually an option
I haven't thought about that but that's
that's a legitimate option if what we're
gonna try to do now ends up just not
looking good or being confusing then we
may try to do that so I think that's a
good idea Youssef thank you Oh answers
you could show a menu history at the top
yeah actually these are all really good
ideas I'm definitely gonna have to
consider these as an alternative Puyo
says am I the only one who finds
JavaScript frameworks like angular or
react very difficult after how many
years you started working with one I
find them difficult at first I mean I've
only been working with reactor II about
a year maybe a year and a few months and
I'm very comfortable with it now I mean
I would not say I'm an expert at all but
I don't find it difficult so but at
first I did and when I first worked with
angular I found it difficult now I
didn't stick with angular so it's
probably still difficult for me if I
would try it but I think it's just you
know like any new thing it's gonna be
difficult at first and it you know some
frameworks just take longer to get
from within others I yeah I mean it's I
think that's just the way it is with any
new you know new framework it's actually
we're doing the stream without the
camera like on my face because now I'm
like I don't have to think about it
normally have to think that I don't do
anything weird on camera but and I have
to think like okay I need to make sure
my face is actually in the camera but
now like I can sit like really slaps
down in my chair and lean back
anyway let me keep going I'm almost
through the live chat now you check the
time
okay good this is I'm gonna have to end
things at like 10 minutes at the most
let's see Ian
oops sorry not Ian
oh I see Ian was responding to my
question so I asked if anyone else had
the issue where you try to do something
that you've done a million times before
and like for some reason you just can't
remember the syntax and so Ian sits all
the time thanks thanks for that I'm glad
I'm not the only one Jacob says Mac or
Windows for programming use such as Mac
or Linux honestly I really do like Mac
for programming I haven't I haven't used
a linux as an operating like a desktop
operating system I haven't use Linux
I've used it on servers though and I
like it so I'm kind of used to Linux and
Mac right now I used the program but for
years I programmed on a Windows machine
so there are pros and cons I think to
everything but right now I I do really
like programming on a Mac
so I don't know that I could give a
great answer for it Jacobs has been
wanting to learn HTML CSS but I'm having
a hard time self teaching myself
watching to see any suggestions Youssef
says watching tutorials makes it easy
for me Jacob says anyone know of any
teachers in person I don't want to wait
for college yeah I am that's tough I
mean I guess you could try so you don't
have to wait for college so I'm assuming
you're maybe in high school then it's
gonna be tough so like normally you
could go to a boot camp like in person
but if you're in high school I mean
maybe you could find a boot camp that's
during like summer break from high
school and I'd say that's that's
probably you know the most likely way
that you have of finding an in-person
teacher yeah so I would say that unless
you can find someone in your area like
maybe like a meet-up like a web
developer meetup and see about getting
like a mentor on anyone else have any
other ideas for how Jacob can find like
someone to help in person in learning
HTML and CSS
hey amenities here how's it going thanks
for watching
Carlos says check the free code camp
website for learning oh yeah if you
haven't already tried free code camp go
to free cookie org and start in with
some of those lessons I mean they it's
still gonna be like you have to motivate
yourself to do it but hmm sorry I won't
but it is it has helped a lot of people
to learn aim star asked what font we're
using for menu items it's Roboto I
believe that we were using a 400 font
weight right here and the color is rgba
0 0 0.5 for which I mean you can see all
that if you check out the repository
all right Aaron asked if there's a
stream or video to see what it did to
get to this point there are actually a
lot of streams this is the fifty-fifth
stream for this project so you can go
back through and check out all the
streams that is it's gonna be a lot
might not be a bad idea to do a recap
video yeah maybe I'll have to think
about doing a recap video because 55
streams is quite a lot especially since
almost every stream is over an hour long
I mean that's literally days of non-stop
watching to get through it
I do recommend watching old streams of
on like faster than normal speed I
usually talk like somewhat slowly so you
can still understand me on to time speed
let's see
my mommy says last time you said you'll
be live on Monday I know I know I've
Monday yesterday I'm sorry I forgot to
apologize for this I know I said I'd be
live on Monday but yesterday just filled
up with meetings so since I've been
working from home a lot all my meetings
have to fit into the like two days that
I'm I'm at work this week I'm actually
gonna be in three days but so then my
days filled with meetings so I ended up
like having several people over the
weekend asked me for meetings so then my
schedule just got full one meeting ended
up getting canceled so I probably could
have Street squeeze the stream in but it
didn't and know that it got cancelled
until it was like really close to the
meeting time so I do I apologize for
that it's just like I said it my
schedule just filled up you know the day
before so I mean sometimes that happens
so I can't I can't you know say no I
can't meet with you because of the live
stream so try to be respectful about
that so that I can keep doing the live
stream on campus
Andy says oh I never mind Andy was
asking somebody else something in the
chat in a asks is it hard to do a dev
job without experience there's just a
lot of learning involved so I mean yeah
it's it's hard you know because starting
on anything new is is hard oh you know
what actually I think I misread that I
think in a correct me if I'm wrong but I
to get it oh I see later on you
corrected it is it hard to get a dev job
without experience yeah it can be a lot
of places are looking for experience but
don't be afraid to apply and try to make
up for that lack of experience with a
really good portfolio even if that
portfolio is just side projects that you
made on your own it really doesn't
matter if their projects and their
functional and their good projects you
know then whoever's you're applying to
you know they can see the quality they
can see the code they can see the the
project so that's that's how you would
make up then for the lack of experience
and then always try to get projects on
the side even if even if you have to do
volunteer stuff if you can afford to
take some time to do volunteer things at
least that's something you could put
down you know that you build this
website for this company
alright you don't they don't need to
know how much money you made off of it
or if you made any money at all you know
so that can that can help convince a
company that even though you don't have
a lot of experience you do know what
you're doing so but I mean I don't want
to mislead it is going to be hard it's
definitely easier if you have that
experience but it's not impossible you
know you just have to kind of be
creative and in building up that
portfolio and presenting yourself you
know in the right way of you know on
your resume like really emphasize your
projects where if somebody else might
emphasize their work experience if they
had a lot you know don't worry about
that on your
they you know put your projects up at
the top and breasts impress them first
and then once they get down to the
bottom and see all there's not much work
experience they're already gonna like
you so they're gonna be way more likely
to overlook the the lack of work
experience right does that make sense
let's see Andy asked how do you
structure your react projects I mean
what right now we're using next Jas so
we really just use the folder structure
that that's built out with next
sometimes we use create react apps so we
pretty much stick with that structure
tech expert says hello I know CSS and
JavaScript HTML CSS and JavaScript what
should I learn next and your choice
between PHP and nodejs right now
I choose nodejs right now I'm not saying
there's anything wrong with PHP but if
you know JavaScript for front-end it's
so much easier to just pick up node node
can do so many different things the only
disadvantage right now for node is that
a lot of cheap hosting providers don't
let you use node but they will let you
use PHP so like if you're gonna go with
GoDaddy share hosting or something
you're not at least last time I checked
you're not gonna be able to use node so
that's that's really the only thing but
you know the people that are using the
cheap hosting providers like that they I
don't that's probably not where you'd
want to get if you're really into coding
and want to develop like cool things
with node or something like that like
those are the clients that are gonna
have the money to pay you for something
like that anyway they're not the clients
they're gonna be able to pay for a lot
of custom stuff so it's not like you'd
be doing a lot of custom PHP you
probably be setting up a wordpress site
but I I go with node I only do PHP when
I really have to and I focus on learning
node you know better so that would be my
recommendation
himemiya says I wonder why everyone is
using rubato and Latino fonts we use
Roboto because it's in the material
design specification so I mean yeah
that's that's just what we use I mean I
think it's a good font I think the odds
of people being familiar with it and
like having a cache in the browser are
pretty good as well so it's a free font
Raphael asks a lovely name Raphael I
name my oldest son Raphael so awesome
name but Raphael s Jessie which Mac are
you using right now I have an iMac and
I'll bring up the specs for you here
it's gonna be hard to see it's kind of
small
but it's the iMac retina 5k 27-inch late
2014 I'm running four gigahertz intel
core i7 and 32 gigabytes of RAM and I
have two external monitors connected to
it I have the 2k 27-inch screen on one
side and then I have a 1080p screen in
vertical alignment on the other side you
see FS about meteor J s I don't know
that much about meteor I've seen some
presentations where people do really
cool things with meteor but I don't have
personal experience with it so I guess
all I know is that you can make really
awesome things with me to your jazz and
that's about the extent of my knowledge
of meteor hey harsh it's here how's it
going hard [ __ ] illnesses thank you for
your answer you're welcome hopefully
that that helped in and if you ever need
help with like job trying to get a job
or resume stuff or anything like just
let me know you know send me a message
through whatever social media and I'd be
happy to like check out your portfolio
or your resume and yes just just let me
know Raphael says thanks Jesse yeah no
problem
mmm he says that's a lot of RAM I know
is I had 16 to start out with in the
the guy that works in the office next to
me told me that he upgraded a 32 and
then I was like all right I got upgraded
32 so I did but it I mean it helps I
always have like a million tabs open in
Chrome and in my computer is always fast
so it's definitely it definitely helps
see technics versus where to find cool
projects to practice for web dev I mean
you can check out the projects for free
code camp and practice on those I mean
those are some pretty cool projects like
a weather app there are some games that
you can make so I mean there's a lot of
cool ideas for projects so you could
either like following the instructions
exactly on free code camp or you could
just let it be inspiration for you for
other things that you want to do that's
free code camp org breakfast is awesome
setup Thanks
I love that more than three monitors
because I used to run with four monitors
but I you can't
like by default you can't hook up a
third monitor to an iMac I've read it
there are some ways that you can make it
work but it's not really easy the mummy
says can I send you my resume yeah go
ahead
send it to me I guess well you can you
can check in the description of this
video there should be a link to my
youtube channel and then from there I
have all my different social media sites
there so get in touch with me on
whatever social media site and you know
you can send me a resume like that let
me give you all my my email
all right so I just put my email on the
live chat it's just Jessie why go
gmail.com you send me something there -
probably through social media is more
reliable because like it won't
accidentally end up in the spam folder
or something but if you want to email me
that's I mean that's also an option so I
can't guarantee that like I'll get back
to you in a certain amount of time
because I mean sometimes I'm just really
busy but I will try to get back to
everybody at some point if you've asked
me something in the past and I didn't
get back to you please remind me because
sometimes I do get a lot of messages and
things just kind of get forgotten and
lost and it takes a long time to scroll
back to where that message was so it's
entirely possible that I have forgotten
about answering some of you who may have
asked me something and I really don't
want to do that so so please remind me
if if I have done that and if so I
apologize okay
so I've gone past the time that I had to
be somewhere so now I am late so I'm
gonna end now and thank you all for
watching I should be able to stream
tomorrow
so hopefully I'll be back tomorrow and I
guess we'll work on this probably we'll
work on this component a little bit more
yeah so until then have a wonderful day